We'll see a few examples in just a moment, and we'll see why this formula works.
Now, it might not be clear why we would want to take a function and express it as a matrix like this,
but it does make sense to do this. One of the reasons, and perhaps, it's the main reason, is that if we have a system
in a probabilistic state
and we perform a deterministic
operation on that system, then the resulting probabilistic
state can be obtained
by matrix-vector multiplication, i.e., if our system is
in a probabilistic state
that's represented by
some probability vector v and we perform the deterministic
operation described by M
on that system, then the resulting probabilistic state will be given by M times v.
Here, by the way, this arrow with a little
bar on it like this is just a common notation in mathematics for indicating how one
thing gets mapped to
or transformed into another thing. You could just use an ordinary arrow, but this is conventional
and it's recognizable and maybe it's a little bit more specific than just an arrow, which could mean many different things.
Now let's take a look at an example or a collection of examples, really.
Let's consider what happens when we take our classical state set sigma to be once again the binary alphabet.
There aren't too many different functions of the form we've been discussing when this is our classical state set and to be more precise, there are just four
functions of this form.
Here, those four functions are described by their so-called tables of values.
The first table describes
the first function, which we've named f1.
For each possible input on the left, we list the corresponding
output on the right, so f1 of zero is equal to zero,
and f1 of one is, again, equal to zero, and that is to say that f1 is
the constant zero function.
It always takes the value zero.
The second function f2
is the identity function.
The output is always equal to the input as you can see from the second table.
The third function f3 is
described by the third table.
f3 of zero is equal to one, and f3 of one is equal to zero.
This function is better
known as the not function or logical negation.
We sometimes also call it a bit flip because it flips zero
to one and one to zero.
The last function f4 is,
again, a constant function just like the first one, but this one is the constant one function
because it always takes the value one.
And those are the only four functions from the binary alphabet to itself.
Here are the four matrices that correspond to these four functions that are described by
the formula from before,
which you can see right here, and if you're so inclined, you can pause the video and check this.
Just remember that with matrices, the order of the indices is always rows first, column second.
So the b, a entry corresponds
to row b and column a or the row that corresponds
to the classical state b
and the column that corresponds
to the classical state a.
So for example, if we look
at the first function, we have the f1 of zero is equal to zero
and correspondingly, the
zero, zero entry of M1 is equal to one.
Well, the one, zero
entry which is right here is equal to zero, and you can do the same thing for the case
where the input is equal to one and similarly, for the
other three functions.
You can also check that this
formula from before is true and you can just go one by one through all the different
possibilities to verify this.
And in fact, if you think about the way that
matrix multiplication works, really you can just kind of eyeball this.
When you multiply a matrix to a standard basis factor like this, you can imagine that
you're taking the input
and dropping it into the
top of one of the matrices in whichever column corresponds
to the classical state
inside of the ket, and the output that you
get is simply that column as a probability vector.
So for example, M3 multiplied to ket
zero gives you zero, one
as a probability vector, which is ket one.
M3 multiplied to ket
one gives you one, zero, which is ket zero and so on.
We'll discuss operations on
probabilistic states more in just a moment, but first, let's introduce the second part of the Dirac notation.
This is gonna be helpful
for talking about operations and thinking about them as major Cs, and it's also gonna be a standard tool
that we'll continue to use going forward. The setup is just like it was before.
We have whatever classical state set sigma that we're working with and we assume that we have some way of
ordering those classical states.
We then write this thing
that you see right here where this time the
angled bar is on the left rather than the right to mean
the row vector having a one
in the entry that
corresponds to a and a zero for all of the other entries corresponding to all the
other classical states.
So the difference between
this thing and ket a is that this is a row vector and
ket a is a column vector,